So let's assume we want to make a movies website.
Much like this one. Now, if you were to make
this based on what we have been doing this far.
What we would do is start with an empty programming file,
and we would like it something like movies.py. Now, since
a movie has a lot of data associated with it,
like the movies title, its storyline, we would add that
to our program. Also, we would want to do things with
our movies, like show the movies trailer or
show or print all of the movies information. So
we would add those function to our code as
well. So far, so good. So, further imagine that
we want to run this program. And we want
to play a movie's trailer. Well, which movie's trailer?
To make that work, we would have to provide
the show_trailer function some information or arguments, like this.
In this case we are saying hey,
play Toy Story's, youtube_url. That seems manageable
enough. Now let's try to print out
a movies information. Well, which movies information?
Again we would have to supply some sort of information or arguments, to the
show_info function. Arguments like the movie's title,
its storyline, the release_date, rating, youtube_url, director,
box_office, et cetera. Now, I don't know about you,
but this function show_info is already getting too convoluted
for me. Imagine what happens if we have to
supply more information to it. Like the movie's cast
or the movie's reviews. What we really want to do
is define a template for our movie and record
all of the data that needs to go into
that template. Data like the move's title, it's storyline and
functions like show_trailer and show information and then simply say,
hey, Toy Story is a movie and so is Avatar.
And then have the ability to say, show me Toy
Stories trailer or show me Avatar's information. No arguments necessary.
Now, one way of doing this, just by using functions, is to take the template
we have defined and make multiple copies of it. So, we could make a copy
of this template and call it toy_story.py, and make another copy of this
template, and call it avatar.py. Now we will be able to say things like
toy_story.show_trailer and avatar.show_info. Now,
this doesn't seem like a very smart solution to me.
Imagine what happens, if we have to add more pieces of
data to our template. Or if you have to rename one
of our functions. Say, from, show_trailer to play_trailer. If that happens,
we will have to make those changes in each and
every copy that we make. This doesn't seem like a very
smart thing to do. So what we really need is a
way of making copies of a template, without having multiple files.
We need the ability to define a template for
something, like we did for movies, and then be
able to say, hey, Toy Story is a type
of that template, and so is Avatar. Avatar is also
a type of that template. We need something new,
and that new thing in programming is called a
class. So what are classes and how do you
use them? Let's find out in the next few lessons.